schnell aufgetretene Rückenschmerzen und die strahlen ins linke Bein aus.
Aber die Schmerzen sind mehr im Bein als im Rücken und die Schmerzen gehen so bis in den großen Zeh.
Seit drei Tagen, ich werde nochmal zusammenfassen,
seit drei Tagen, Sie haben eine Rückenschmerzen, die Schmerzen strahlen bis in den Bein.
Ja, bis in den großen Zeh, bis in den Fuß.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben? Wie ist die Schmerzen? Eine drückende oder brennende?
Ja, mehr drückend und ein drückender Schmerz.
Gibt es einen Auslöser, der Ihre Schmerzen verstärkt oder verhindert?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich muss in meinem Beruf viel heben und tragen.
Ich bin Landschaftsgärtner. Da musste ich viel Säcke mit Erde tragen und mit Dünger, Blühemittel.
Vor drei, vier Tagen musste ich besonders viel schwere Säcke tragen. Vielleicht hängt es damit zusammen. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzenskala? Von eins bis zehn. Wobei zehn unerträglich ist.
Ich würde sagen mindestens fünf bis sechs. Wenn ich husten muss oder niesen muss oder mich anders bewege, dann können sie auch mal sieben sein.
Sie haben Schmerzen auch in Ruhe oder in Ruhe.
Verlindert Ihre Schmerzen, wenn Sie im Liege?
Ja, wenn ich mich hinlege und die Knie etwas anziehe, dann sind die Schmerzen etwas besser. Aber sie sind immer da.
Aber Sie taub heißt Gefühle?
Ja, im Unterschenkel besonders. Mehr vorne im Unterschenkel und im mittleren Bereich. Das geht bis in den Fuß, bis in den Zeh.
Haben Sie auch Gewichtgefühlverlust?
Ja, ich glaube, dass das ein bisschen taub ist.
Auch direkt in der Seite, wo es wehtut, wo der Hauptschmerz ist.
Haben Sie Schmerzen oder Versteck, die Sie beim Hüsten, starken Hüsten oder?
Ja, beim Husten wird das schlimmer oder beim Niesen.
Beim Niesen, Stuhlgang auch?
Nein, beim Stuhlgang ist mir das nicht so aufgefallen. Aber hauptsächlich beim Husten.
Sie können gerade normalen laufen oder eine Humpenlaufe?
Ich kann nicht normal laufen. Ich kann das linke Bein nicht so gut belasten. Da ist nicht so viel Kraft drin.
Beide Fuß?
Nein, nur links, wo der Schmerz ist.
Linkes Schmerz, ja. Sie haben Schmerzen rechte Seite oder linke Seite?
Links.
Links, ok. Ich habe falsch geschrieben. Entschuldigung.
Aber Sie haben nicht ganz normal laufen. Sie müssen ein bisschen humpeln laufen.
Ja, ich muss etwas humpeln. Ganz schlecht ist Treppensteigen. Das ist nicht gut.
Da kann ich mit dem linken Fuß nicht zuerst setzen. Da knick ich ein. Da habe ich zu wenig Kraft.
Beim Laufen stoppelt Ihr linken Fuß auch?
Gestolpert bin ich bisher nicht. Aber ich habe mich wenig bewegt, weil die Bewegung auch den Schmerz verstärkt.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, ein Haarverlust, Haarausfall im Bein?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen wie einen elektrischen Schock beschreiben oder nicht?
Wie einen elektrischen Schock? Manchmal. Aber nicht immer. Manchmal, wenn er sich verstärkt.
Wie ein kleiner Blitz.
Ja, ich würde das sagen. Wie ein kleiner Blitz.
Waren Sie schon einmal beim Arzt?
Nein, war ich noch nicht. Das ist auch erst seit drei Tagen.
Vor drei Tagen hatten Sie keine Beschwerden?
Nein, nein. Ganz null.
Das ist jetzt neu.
Haben Sie Schmerzen auf Wasser lassen?
Nein, habe ich nicht. Nein. Stoßang, Wasser lassen.
Hatten Sie früher ein Rückenproblem?
Nein, ich hatte schon mal Rückenschmerzen, aber nicht so.
Auch nicht, dass die Beschmerzen ins Bein einstrahlen. So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Sind bei Ihnen Vorerkrankungen und OP bekannt?
Ja, Vorerkrankungen. Ich habe hohen Blutdruck.
Hoher Blutdruck. Seit wann?
Hoher Blutdruck habe ich seit 5 Jahren.
5 Jahre. Okay. Nehmen Sie Medikamente?
Ja, da nehme ich zwei verschiedene Medikamente ein. Einmal heißt das Mittel Bisopolol.
Wie viele Dosierungen?
Dahinter steht 5.
Wie viele nehmen Sie?
Morgens eine und abends eine halbe Tablette.
Morgens eine und abends halbe Tablette.
Ja, und dann nehme ich noch Rami-Prel.
5 steht da auch hinter. Dann nehme ich morgens eine und abends eine.
Morgen, abends eine.
Außer Hochdruck, haben Sie auch noch andere Krankheiten?
Nein.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich wurde operiert als Kind. Da war ich vielleicht 9 Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert.
Mandeln?
Ja, im Alter von 18 Jahren wurde ich am Blinddarm operiert.
Blinddarm.
Und dann hatte ich mit 20 Jahren einen Unfall mit dem Moped, mit dem Motorrad.
Und da habe ich mir meinen Unterschenkel rechts gebrochen, das Schienenbein.
Schienenbein.
Und das musste operiert werden.
Musste operiert werden.
Nachdem wie verlief war normal nach dem OP?
Ja, das war alles gut.
Die Implantate reingestellt oder wie behandelt das?
Also die am Unterschenkel wurde, so nach anderthalb Jahren, wurde Metall entfernt.
Metall entfernt, eineinhalb. Eineinhalb Jahre, ja?
Ja, also ungefähr. Ich kann mich nicht mehr genau erinnern.
Wie eine Schraube, das war eine draußen Schraube.
Ja, da waren Schrauben drin.
Außen, ja?
Auch so eine Platte auch.
Eine Platte.
Ja, aber ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Jedenfalls wurde das wieder rausgenommen.
Wie war eine Ring und draußen eine Schraube, ja?
Das war Ring.
Kann sein, aber da müssten Sie eventuell Berichte anfordern von meinem Hausarzt.
Der hat die Berichte noch.
Okay. Ich würde gerne wissen, außer diese Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein auch?
Nein, ich nehme nur die zwei Mittel für den Blutdruck, gegen den Blutdruck ein.
Okay. Haben Sie schon etwas genommen gegen diese Beschwerden, ein Schmerzmittel, ich meinte?
Ich habe gestern mal eine Ibuprofen genommen.
Ibuprofen, das war so eine, die man kaufen kann.
400 steht dahinter. Die habe ich genommen, aber ich habe keine große Verbesserung gemerkt.
Keine große Verbesserung. Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergie und Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein.
Nein, keine Allergie. Okay. Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Was kindert auch?
Ich rauche schon seit 30 Jahren ungefähr eine Schachtel am Tag.
Eine Schachtel am Tag. Okay.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Ich trinke abends eine Flasche Bier zum Abendbrot, Abendessen.
So trinke ich abends schon eine Flasche Bier, aber mehr nicht.
Eine Flasche Bier. Okay.
Nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine routinische Frage.
Ich muss jede Patientin diese Frage stellen.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Nein. Danke. Danke für die Angabe.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie eine wichtige chronische Erkrankung, die ich wissen soll?
Mein Vater ist 75 Jahre alt, der hat Alterszucker seit einiger Zeit und der hat seit einigen Jahren auch hohen Blutdruck.
Er noch?
Also zwei Sachen, Alterszucker und hohen Blutdruck.
Die Mutter ist 74 Jahre alt, die hat auch Alterszucker und die hat Arthrose.
Und zwar in der Ökologie.
Im Knie und Hüfte.
Knie und Hüfte. Okay.
Haben Sie auch Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, der ist 48 Jahre alt, der hat hohes Cholesterin.
Ja, da nimmt er auch Medikamente, aber ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen, welche.
Und er hat Probleme mit der Haut, er hat Schuppenflechte.
Schuppenflechte, ja. Schuppenflechte, okay. Danke.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, wir sind verheiratet, wir haben zwei Kinder.
Die sind gesund?
Ja, die sind gesund, die sind 15 Jahre alt und 14 Jahre.
15 und 14, ja?
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie arbeiten als Bauarbeiter?
Ja, ich bin Gärtner.
Ich arbeite viel draußen, wir bauen Mauern im Garten und so weiter.
Das ist eine schwere körperliche Arbeit.
Sie müssen etwas schwerer haben, ja?
Ja, ja.
Waren Sie schon in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Ich war in Spanien, Valencia, zehn Tage lang, das war im März, aber sonst war ich nicht im Ausland.
Haben Sie etwas wie einen Hautausschlag bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht so genau.
Ich habe meine Impfungen gekriegt, Tetanus und Diphterie, das muss ich immer haben, Tetanus, weil ich mich auch manchmal verletze.
Ich habe auch die Impfungen für die Arbeit und Corona gemacht.
Spezialimpfungen wie für Reisen, die manche machen müssen, das mache ich nicht, weil ich solche Reisen nicht mache.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Früher habe ich Sport gemacht, aber in den letzten zehn Jahren nicht mehr.
Letzten zehn Jahre nicht mehr.
Ich werde nochmal gucken, Herr Haskinkow.
Eigentlich habe ich meinerseits alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder möchten Sie etwas wissen?
Ja, ich hoffe, dass Sie mir bald helfen können, dass Sie bald herausfinden, was ich habe und dass man das gut behandeln kann,
weil ich möchte eigentlich auch wieder arbeiten.
Ja, genau.
Zuerst möchte ich Sie fragen, möchten Sie gerade eine Schmerzmittel?
Nein, wenn das jetzt nicht zu lange dauert, brauche ich jetzt keine Schmerzmittel.
Aufgrund der Analyseung und der Schmerzen, habe ich den Verdacht, dass eine Bandscheibung vorgefallen ist.
Die Schmerzen zeigen sich als Bandscheibung vorgefallen.
Die Umzucht oder die Beschreibung ist genau so.
Wir müssen einige Neurologik-Untersuchungen durchführen.
Neurologik-Untersuchungen.
Danach würde ich gerne ein bisschen Blut abnehmen.
Und wir brauchen ein Bildgebungsverfahren.
Ich möchte zuerst eine Rundgänge.
Danach werde ich die MRT veranlassen.
Okay, gut. MRT, was heißt das?
MRT, Magnetik Resonanz Tomographie.
Sie würden in einem geschlossenen Platz liegen.
Sie müssen ein bisschen dort bleiben.
Es ist eine schmerzfreie und strahlfreie Methode.
Es dauert ungefähr 10 oder 15 Minuten, je nach der Lokalisation und Untersuchung.
Aber es ist 100% schmerzfrei.
Haben Sie Angst, dass Sie auf einem geschlossenen Platz bleiben?
Nein.
Es ist ein bisschen halb geschlossen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Gut, dann machen wir das so.
Haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, die Fachbegriffe sich zurechtzulegen, vorzubereiten?
Dann machen wir gleich die Vorstellung.
Hat jemand noch Ergänzungsfragen?
Oder würde jemand noch was anderes fragen bei diesen Beschwerden von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen?
Man könnte noch fragen, hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit gestürzt?
Oder ist irgendetwas passiert in den letzten Tagen?
Das könnte man noch fragen.
Also Trauma erfragen sollte man vielleicht noch tun.
Aber ansonsten, denke ich, haben Sie die wesentlichen Dinge auch erfragt.
Sollte ich fragen, die urologische Untersuchung?
Ich meine die Prostatuntersuchung, irgendetwas?
Jetzt würde ich noch gar nichts. Sie waren meine Fragen.
Musste ich fragen?
Nein, wenn der Patient so ungefähr sagt, Hauptsache Sie können mir helfen,
dann können Sie natürlich sagen, jetzt muss ich Sie erstmal körperlich untersuchen.
Dann kann ich mir schon ein Bild machen.
Dann müssen wir eventuell Zusatzuntersuchungen machen wie Bildgebung, wie Labor.
Würde ich mich mit einer Diagnose, auch wenn die Diagnose vielleicht klar ist,
würde ich mit einer Diagnose noch vorsichtig sein.
Man kann sagen, es kann etwas mit Ihrer Bandscheibe zu tun haben, mit Ihrer Wirbelsäule.
Aber da müssen wir noch weitere Untersuchungen machen.
Als erstes erstmal eine gründliche körperliche Untersuchung.
Da kann ich schon noch mehr Informationen bekommen.
Das können Sie aufgrund der klinischen Symptomatik dann auch eventuell durch eine Reflexdiagnostik,
Kraftgrad, den Patienten sich bewegen lassen.
Da kann man schon viele zusätzliche Informationen bekommen,
die schon zu einer Diagnose oder einer Eingrenzung einer Diagnose führen.
Aber ich wäre mit Diagnosen, deswegen ich frage ja immer als Patient,
wäre ich noch immer etwas defensiv, vorsichtig, etwas zurückhaltend.
Sagen Sie, wir brauchen noch mehr Informationen für eine seriöse, gründliche Diagnose.
Da machen Sie nichts falsch.
Genau.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt ein paar Minuten Zeit und lasse ich Sie in Ruhe.
Und dann stellen Sie bitte den Patienten mir vor, dann bin ich der Oberarzt. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich, danke.
So.
Ja, wollen wir?
Ja, bitte.
Okay, ich bin nicht bereit. Ich werde versuchen.
Ja.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt. Haben Sie Kurse seit?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich würde gerne einen Patienten vorstellen.
Klaus Haskinkow ist 50 Jahre alt, am 19.07.1975 geboren,
wiegt aktuell 82 Kilogramm und 1 Meter 84 groß.
Er stellt sich seit 3 Tagen bestehende Lumbargie vor.
Schmerzen sei drückend. Er könne nicht richtig laufen.
Er habe unkernes Bildgang.
Wo ist der Hauptschmerz?
Der Patente hat gesagt,
der Hauptschmerz ist mehr im Unterschenkel.
Mehr im Unterschenkel. Entschuldigung.
Also ist vielleicht ganz wichtig, so ein bisschen als,
vielleicht später so in der Diagnostik schon mal anamnestisch.
Also der Hauptschmerz, er hat Rückenschmerzen und Ausstrahlung in das linke Bein,
besonders bis in den linken großen Zeh, in den Hallux.
Schmerz, Punktum Maximum ist mehr im Unterschenkel.
Genau.
Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Schmerzen-Schkala 5 bis 6 von 10.
Laut Patienten verstärkt Lumbargie beim höchsten Niesenvagalen Reaktionen,
meist an vagalen Reaktionen.
Die Frage nach den Wasserlassenproblemen,
Haarausverlust und Durchgangsprobleme wurden verneint.
Sagen Sie da ruhig, es bestehen keine Miktionsstörungen oder Defektionsstörungen.
Wir fragen ja sonst immer eventuell nach Sphincter-Insuffizienz,
Sphincterschwäche, Inkontinenz oder so.
Aber sagen Sie ruhig, es bestehen keine Miktionsstörungen und keine Defektionsstörungen.
Dann haben Sie das Thema. Ist das in Ordnung?
Danke schön.
Genau.
Den Patienten zufolge hat er mehr Schmerzen beim Treppe steigen.
In Ruhe und im Liege verlindert er die Schmerzen.
Ja.
Er hat schon 400 mg Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Es war nicht geholfen.
Ohne wesentliche Besserung.
Ohne Besserung, genau.
Die Frage nach Verletzung und Unfall wurden verneint.
Ohrerkrankungen OP.
Hat der Patient eine Erklärung für seine Schmerzen, für die Ursache?
Kann er irgendwas sagen?
Ja, sie hat letztes Tages eine Belastung.
Sie musste viel arbeiten, viele schwere Dinge auftragen.
Er, der Patient.
Er musste viele schwere Dinge heben und auftragen.
Er arbeitete als Gartner.
Als Gartner musste er viele Dinge heben und auftragen.
Und letztes Tages war es ein bisschen schwierig für ihn.
Entschuldigung.
Können Sie mir noch sagen, nochmal mit den Beschwerden im Bein.
Sie haben den Patienten sicher gefragt nach Taubheitsgefühl oder...
Ja, Taubheitsgefühl.
Wie würden Sie das medizinisch beschreiben?
Er berichtet über Parasite und Parasite.
Manchmal sagen wir Kribbelparasite wie Kribbeln.
Wie eine Ameise über die Haut läuft.
Kribbelparasitin, ja, okay.
Gibt es Hauteffloreszenzen?
Nein, er hat keine Hautveränderung.
Ich fasse einmal kurz zusammen.
Es handelt sich um einen 50-jährigen Patienten.
Normgewichtig, der seit drei Tagen über akut aufgetretene
Lumbarischalgie klagt.
Nicht nur Lumbarischalgie, sondern Lumbarischalgie.
Mit Ausstrahlung bis in den linken Groß C, bis in den Hallux.
Es besteht eine Schmerzverschlimmerung bei Hustenschmerz oder Tussis.
Und bei Bewegung.
Entlastung hat der Patient in Rückenlage,
die Beine etwas anzieht, Knie anzieht.
Als Wurzelentlastungsschmerz.
Miktionsstörungen oder Defektionsstörungen werden verneint.
Der Schmerzgrad liegt ungefähr bei VHS 5 bis 6.
Und bei Verschlimmerung durch Husten und Bewegung bis 7.
Gut, das ist so erstmal das Wesentliche.
Ein Unfallereignis wird auch verneint.
Der Patient ist von Beruf Gärtner und muss häufig schwere Lasten und Säcke tragen und heben.
Ich kann sagen, es ist sciatische Schmerzen.
Ich muss nur einfach Lumbarischalgie.
Lumbarischalgie heißt eigentlich Schmerz im Rücken und Ausstrahlung im Bereich des Ischiasnervs.
Das würde ich erstmal so... Sie sagen ja erstmal nur, was der Patient schildert.
Sie haben ja noch keine genauen Befunde erhoben.
Sie haben noch keinen Reflexstatus erhoben und so weiter.
Den Kraftgrad noch nicht gemessen.
Der Patient berichtet weiterhin, dass er über eine Kraftminderung im linken Bein
besonders beim Treppensteigen merkt er das.
Da ist er unsicher und die Kraftminderung ist da.
Gut, können Sie mir etwas sagen zu chronischen Erkrankungen bei dem Patienten?
Ja, er hat arterielle Hypertonik seit vier und vor Jahren.
Er nimmt dagegen bisoprol 5 mg einmal morgen halb Abend.
Ramipril 5 mg einmal morgen, einmal Abend.
Mit neun Jahren hat er Tonsillektomie.
Mit 18 Appendektomie und mit 20 wegen eines Unfalls eine tibiale Fraktur operiert werden.
Ja, eine Tibiafraktur.
Aufgrund eines Unfalls musste er wegen einer Tibiafraktur im Alter von 20 Jahren operiert werden.
Und können Sie mir etwas zur Familienanamnese sagen?
Der Vater leidet an Diabetes Typ 2 und arterielle Hypertonik.
Wie alt ist der Vater?
Der Vater ist gerade 75 Jahre alt.
Die Mutter ist 74 Jahre alt.
Sie hat auch Diabetes Typ 2 und Coxatros und Gonatros.
Sie leidet an Coxatros und Gonatros.
An oder unter muss ich sagen?
Das ist in Ordnung.
Und gibt es Geschwister?
Er hat einen Bruder.
Er ist 88 Jahre alt.
Er hat Hyperkolesterolemie und Pistoreasis.
Okay, sehr gut.
Gut, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Ja, ich habe den Verdacht...
Eine kurze Frage noch.
Hat der Patient sonst persönliche Risikofaktoren wie Alkohol, Nikotin?
Ja, er raucht.
Rauchen ist eine Risikofaktoren.
Wir können auch rechnen, die Rauchen ist eine wichtige Faktoren.
Er ist 30 Jahre, ein paar Jahre Raucher.
Sie können ruhig sagen, es besteht ein Nikotinkonsum von 30 Packages.
Er braucht jeden Tag ein Päckchen.
Und man kann eventuell auch sagen, ein Nikotin-Abusus.
Der Patient ist wahrscheinlich nikotinabhängig erst mal.
So schnell stellt man das nicht ein, in der Regel.
Können Sie nochmal wiederholen?
Ja, es besteht ein Nikotinabusus von 30 Packages.
Von 30 Packages.
Das kann man ruhig so formulieren.
Etwas abgemildert, etwas schwächer ausgedrückt kann man auch sagen,
es besteht ein regelmäßiger Nikotinkonsum von 30 Packages.
Es besteht jeden Tag ein Päckchen.
Aufgrund der anämestischen Angabe und geschilderten Beschwerden
habe ich den Verdacht auf eine vertebral Härnin.
Die Härnin hat sehr große Symptome.
Und als differenzierter Diagnostik
kommen Muskelentspannungen
oder Muskelphasen, Rissen, kann ich sagen.
Was kann ich sagen?
Prostatenhyperplasie oder Prostatmeteplase.
Ich würde jetzt als Diagnose sagen,
der Patient hat eine Lumboischialgie
mit einem Wurzelreizsyndrom.
Eine klassische Symptomatik.
Es besteht der Verdacht auf einen Diskusprolaps.
L5S1 der segmentalen Zuordnung.
Verdacht auf Diskusprolaps L5S1
mit dementsprechender Wurzelreizung.
Dazu zählt die Kraftminderung,
die Kribbelparasthesin.
Der klassische Befund eigentlich.
Differenzialdiagnostisch könnte man auch an eine Zosterneuralgie denken.
Ohne Effloreszenzen.
Es gibt Zoster-Erkrankungen.
Ohne diese typischen Hauteffloreszenzen.
Das ist selten, aber es kommt vor.
Das ist besonders schwierig in der Diagnostik.
Das würde ich zumindest differenzialdiagnostisch.
Eventuell über Blutabklärung.
Das sind die beiden klassischen Sachen.
Aber es spricht viel für eine Wurzelsymptomatik.
Wahrscheinlich durch einen Diskusprolaps.
Es ist kein reiner Lumbalgie.
In Deutschland sagen wir oft Lumbago.
Das ist ein Schmerz, wie sehr häufig ist.
Der mehr im Bereich des tiefen Rückens LWS.
Lumbosakraler Übergang.
Aber ohne die typische Ausstrahlung.
Besonders wenn der Schmerz, das habe ich bei Schmerztherapeuten gelernt.
Wenn ein Schmerz mehr im Bein ist, als im Rücken.
Dann ist es oft ein Hinweis für einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Für einen Diskusprolaps.
Manche sagen, ich habe so starke Schmerzen im Unterschenkel.
Im Rücken habe ich zwar auch Schmerzen.
Aber ganz schlimm sind sie unten im Unterschenkel.
Was können Sie sagen, außer Hepesoster als differenzialdiagnosen?
Was können Sie sagen?
Vielleicht eine Neuritis durch eine Borreliose.
Eventuell.
Aber Sie müssen gar nicht so viele Differenzaldiagnose haben.
Die Myalgie steht nach dieser Behandlung.
Aber eine Myalgie, die typisch bis in den großen C ausstrahlt.
Mit Verstärkung beim Husten.
Der Hustenschmerz oder Niesschmerz.
Das ist oft ein relativ typisches Symptom.
Bei einem Bandscheibenvorfall.
Bei einem Prolaps.
Die Nervenwurzel wird durch den Druck noch mehr geradiziert.
Sie sagen, was ist die Reaktion?
Man kann auch sagen, was ist die Reaktion?
Oder dass Sie ruhig sagen, der Patient berichtet über eine Schmerzverstärkung beim Husten und Niesen.
Er ist nun mal auch Raucher.
Der muss vielleicht auch häufiger mal husten.
Das ist für ihn jetzt besonders schwierig.
Die Frage mit dem Hautausschlag.
Ein Zoster kann mal etwas atypisch verlaufen.
Dass er gar nicht diesen klassischen Ausschlag hat.
Oder nur sehr flüchtig ist.
Nicht so klassisch wie wir das kennen.
Mit dem Bläschenstadium, das manchmal noch länger dauert.
Aber es gibt eben so atypische.
Meine Bitte ist, machen Sie nicht zu früh eine Diagnose.
Wenn der Patient fragt, was kann ich denn haben?
Dann können Sie ruhig in Ihre Denkrichtung was sagen.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, oder wie Sie das schildern, dass Sie Probleme mit der Lindenwirbelsäule haben.
Eventuell mit der Bandscheibe.
Und dass die Bandscheibe auf einen Nerv drückt, der die Schmerzen im Bein verursacht.
Aber das möchte ich gerne durch weitere Untersuchungen untermauern.
Oder Ihnen dann ganz sicher sagen können.
Das wäre jetzt noch zu früh.
Einfach nur zu sagen, das ist die Bandscheibe.
Das kann der Nachbar sagen und der Freund, der kann das sagen.
Diese Vermutung aber, Sie als Arzt sollten sagen, ich muss Sie noch gründlich untersuchen.
Wir müssen eventuell eine Röntgenbildung machen.
Oder eine andere Bildgebung wie eine Computertomographie oder ein MRT, wenn das zur Verfügung steht.
Okay, da ist eine Frage.
Bei der Realität die Prüfung.
Ich kann nicht genau sagen, diese Diagnose befordert.
Diese Untersuchung.
Ich muss Untersuchungen machen und etwas.
Das halte ich in der Medizin für ganz wichtig.
Das ist die Prüfung.
Wenn jemand sagt, aufgrund der Schilderung des Patienten bin ich mit meiner Diagnose mir schon so sicher.
Das kann manchmal richtig sein, aber es kann auch gefährlich sein.
Ich würde dem Patienten immer sagen, wir haben in der Medizin mehrere Diagnoseschritte.
Ich habe Sie jetzt befragt nach Ihren Beschwerden.
Sie haben mir das geschildert.
Ich muss die Diagnose körperlich untersuchen.
Dann kann ich vielleicht mehr sagen, aber Sie müssen aufgrund dieser Sachen noch nicht eine richtige Diagnose stellen.
Das habe ich auch schon mal gehört.
Das war in der Prüfung so gewesen.
Das ist eher total selten.
Sie sollen die Fachsprache beherrschen.
Das muss man unterscheiden.
Die Fachsprache, die Begriffe haben Sie sehr gut gekonnt.
Das ist alles gut.
Aber seien Sie mit Diagnose nicht zu früh stellen.
Etwas abwarten.
Die Patienten wollen immer gerne wissen, was habe ich.
Seien Sie etwas defensiv.
Dann würde ich jetzt erst mal sagen, haben Sie einen Prüfungstermin?
Noch nicht.
Voraussichtlich werde ich in Oktober oder Bekommen.
Ich habe schon angetragen, aber ich warte auf die Meldung.
Haben Sie noch ein bisschen Zeit?
Es steht gerade.
Dann würde ich jetzt erst mal sagen, dass Sie jetzt noch etwas abwarten.
Dann würde ich jetzt erst mal sagen, danke schön.
Ich kann nächste Woche Donnerstag nicht.
Aber in zwei Wochen wieder können wir uns wieder verabreden.
Um 18 Uhr wieder.
Dann würde ich sagen, verbringen Sie einen schönen Abend.
Tschüss.